bonjour alors je vais essayer de parler
trop fort parce que sinon on va
m'entendre un peu trop donc voilà oui je
travaille là dessus et donc la question
c'est est ce qu'il ya des jouets pour
garçons et ce qui est des jouets pour
filles
évidemment comment tout ça se construit
alors il ya des enjeux politiques
derrière les jouets déjà c'est ça qu'il
faut noter un parce qu'on a l'impression
que le jouet c'est anodin finalement
c'est pour les enfants c'est pas très
grave il ya des enjeux politiques
derrière et d'ailleurs ça fait parler
donc quand on regarde cette image on
peut être choqué 1 vous voyez finalement
lassé des extraits du catalogue hyper u
super u où on voit des images atypique
avec des petites filles en train de
s'occuper par exemple de voitures et
puis des garçons de coupons et ça c'est
une image qui est paru sur twitter avec
quelqu'un qui commentait toi aussi
apprend à ton fils à devenir pda et mais
les noirs donc à la fois du racisme de
l'homophobie et du sexisme donc ça fait
parler les jouer quand même ça fait
réagir
donc l environnement social déjà qui
construit les goûts on a tous déjà
observé que souvent les petites filles
préfèrent les poupées souvent les petits
garçons préfèrent les voitures d'où ça
vient est ce que vraiment c'est inné ou
est ce que il ya une construction
sociale
moi je vous parlais de la construction
sociale avant la naissance des gens on
peut savoir si c'est un garçon ou une
fille qui va naître un les parents
peuvent le savoir par le biais de
l'échographie et donc ils vont
développer des attentes normative par
rapport à ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
avec leurs enfants
donc par exemple peut s'imaginer tiens
c'est un petit garçon dont le père pour
aller faire du foot avec lui le week end
donc ils développent des attentes
normative et finalement ils vont
socialiser un leurs enfants en fonction
de ses attentes et donc aussi exercé du
contrôle social quand l'enfant ne
rentrera pas dans les normes qu'il
s'imagine par ailleurs le couple
parental est aussi un observatoire pour
les enfants qui regardent et qui voit
que finalement c'est maman qui fait
l'essentiel du travail domestique quand
on regarde les statistiques et donc du
coup ils sont amenés assez rapidement
finalement associé le travail domestique
à une activité féminine
alors quand on a les objets de l'enfance
par exemple les livres pour enfants on
peut voir ce genre de choses
donc là vous pouvez lire la mère noël
est aux petits soins avec son mari mais
ne fait pas que ça elle est très active
comme tu pourra le constater le père
noël un gros bidon mais ce n'est pas
sans raison tous les soirs il régne hoc
les petits gâteaux préparés par son
épouse la mère noël c'est bien que si
son mari un gros bidon c'est à cause de
ces petits gâteaux
l'inquiétude la mère noël a des doigts
de fée pour rectifier en un rien de
temps
un pantalon un peu trop étroit voilà
donc ça c'est une image qu'on trouve
dans un livre pour enfants qui est très
très vendu avec cette image là où vous
voyez le père noël finalement sur son
fauteuil très tranquille en train de
fumer ce happy de manière un peu
nonchalante les doigts de pied en
éventail
au sens propre avec ses pantoufles ils
ne regardent pas la mère noël il y son
livre 1 tranquillement et puis la mère
noël par contre elle elle est vraiment
penché vers lui elle est en train de le
servir vraiment et puis à lui sourit
elle le regarde on voit même les petits
traits si vous regardez de détail
derrière elle qui montre qu'elle est
vraiment dans cette dans cette action de
servir et puis elle s'assoit pas souvent
un finalement pour se reposer que quand
vous regardez un petit peu son siège
vous avez un chat qui a pris la place et
puis des pelotes de laine qui
l'attendait au cas où elle pourrait
s'assoir à un moment ou à un autre et
puis plein de deux cadres à l'effigié du
père noël un qui lui vraiment et
beaucoup ont valorisé
donc ça c'est le type d'image qu'on peut
trouver dans les livres pour enfants
donc ça questionne et on voit qu'ils
aient des stéréotypes de gens qui sont
diffusées par le biais des objets de
l'enfance donc je viens en marketing du
jouet là vous voyez par exemple des
jouets ménagers avec le panneau vie donc
là ça indique clairement à tout le monde
que le ménage c'est une activité pour
les filles il ya du rose il ya écrit
fille et puis à des photographies de
petite fille et un petit peu partout là
c'est très intéressant si les vélos
c'est ce qu'on appelle des licences donc
la voyez le vélo hello kitty à gauche et
le vélo spider man à droite donc ça ce
sont des licences qui sont
commercialisés par différents fabricants
et ça aujourd'hui c'est ce qui distingue
vraiment peut-être même le plus 1 le
genre féminin du géant masculin ce qu'on
parle beaucoup des couleurs oui rose
pour les filles bleu pour les garçons ex
terrain mais les licences ça contribue
énormément à distinguer les sexes et
donc on sait tous par exemple
abba hellokitty c'est plutôt pour les
filles et donc ça fonctionne sur le plan
marketing pourquoi parce que quand les
parents achètent un vélo quitter pour
leur fille ben c'est difficile ensuite à
transmettre au frère cadet et donc il
faudra acheter un deuxième vélo
donc là on est du côté des fabricants et
vont regarder aussi le jouet vtec par
exemple vous en avez il existe en deux
gamins d'un côté pour les filles et puis
l'autre côté pour les garçons avec une
distinction au niveau des couleurs sur
la boîte de jouer et puis aussi le jouer
en lui-même dont crosin côté bleu
l'autre et puis pour le jouer on a du
rose
et du verre et puis toujours la
photographie qui représente soit un
garçon soit une fille donc ça distingue
bien et ça c'est une segmentation qui
indique aux enfants aux parents à tout
le monde
à qui s'adresse libérant jouer du côté
des fabricants donc là on a un catalogue
deux heureuses on voit que la différence
est très marquée et finalement les
enfants peuvent l'observer même avant de
savoir lire parce que avec les couleurs
il le voit très vite et avec les images
donc là on voit une différence très
marqué et pourtant cette différence
qu'on observe aujourd'hui elle n'a pas
toujours existé où elle n'a pas toujours
été aussi appuyé et ça ça remet un petit
peu en question peut-être les idées
reçues qu'on peut qu'on peut avoir
donc quand on compare avec quelques
années auparavant dont je remonte quand
même 50 ans auparavant
là on a un catalogue au bon marché et on
regarde les à gauche vous avez joué
traditionnellement nous qu'on associe
aux filles et on voit des fonds bleu on
voit un fond bleu et puis du côté droit
des jouets qu'on associe plutôt
traditionnellement garçons on voit un
fond rose
donc voilà déjà au niveau des couleurs
il ya eu un glissement les le rose n'a
pas toujours été assigné au gris et le
bleu aux garçons et finalement ces
images là c'est un extrait 1 mais y'a
d'autres pages où on voit aussi du rose
pour les filles du beau garçon s'est
mélangé un finalement et finalement
quand on regarde les anciens catalogues
de jouets il ya très très peu de
segmentation la segmentation marketing
on observe aujourd'hui
en réalité elle s'est beaucoup
développée au début des années 90 donc
moi j'analyse et de nombreux catalogues
de jouets anciens et j'observe que ben
fin du 19ème jusqu'à aujourd'hui et très
peu de goût de segmentation en réalité
avant les années 90 et même parfois il y
avait des remises en question des
stéréotypes qu'on trouve très peu
aujourd'hui donc à vous avez une image
par exemple du catalogue leclerc 1988 et
marqué tout faire à deux c'est encore
mieux et voyez un garçon et une fille en
train de faire le ménage ensemble un
tous les deux ans à un tablier ce type
d'image ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui
donc pourtant dans les années 80 vous
pouvez trouver ça ouais cette idéologie
un petit peu de bar on va vers le
progrès on va vers l'égalité et ses
terrains bah c'est pas forcément le cas
dans le marketing c'est pas le cas ça
s'accroît de plus en plus cette
segmentation alors légaux par exemple a
créé sa gamme lego freine ce que vous
devez connaître et bien légaux avait
déjà essayé de créer différents une
gamme spécialement pour les filles dans
les années 80 90 et ça n'avait pas
fonctionné
et pourtant la balle et good friends sa
énormément bien points
thione donc qu'est ce qui s'est passé là
c'est on est dans les années 2000 il ya
eu la rencontre entre un public qui peut
être étaient prêts à cette segmentation
à ces inégalités à ces différenciations
garçons filles et puis justement
marketing qui ces demandes de plus en
plus alors pourquoi public était prêt
alors on peut utiliser une féministe
américaine qui s'appelle suzanne fallu
dix qui nous parle de backlash anti
féministe et elle nous dit que ma chaque
fois qu'il ya une avancée historique
dans les droits des femmes et 20 à côté
de ça il ya un retour en arrière donc
1900 dans les années 60 et 70 il ya des
remises en question des stéréotypes de
genre des rôles attribués aux hommes et
aux femmes notamment dans la famille et
dans le travail et puis bah du coup
après il ya aussi un retour en arrière
le retour de bâton si vous voulez dans
les années 80 et 90 ce qu'on remarque
dans le marketing mais finalement le
marketing qui est un symptôme aussi du
reste de la société
mais qui s'autoalimente 1 qui saigne le
marketing aliments de la société la
société allie nantes marketing chez
regarderai alors là c'est anecdotique
moi quand j'étais petit j'avais la
luciole voiliers qui à gauche était
verte et aujourd'hui on la trouve en
magasin sont en bleu sont en rose alors
quelles sont les conséquences sur le
développement des enfants
alors déjà il faut dire que tous les
jouets sont éducatif 1 quand on parle de
jouets éducatifs en général je vous
montre on pense plutôt à ça je sais pas
si vous connaissez si on est de la même
génération la dictée magique
moi j'ai appris un peu à écrire avec ça
quand on pense jouets éducatifs en
france plutôt à ce genre de choses vont
sauf que en fait les jouets sont tous
éducatif parce que les jouets en cinq
tous des choses aux enfants et notamment
ils peuvent diffuser des stéréotypes de
genre donc anne dafflon novelle qui est
psychologue nous dit dans ce processus
de construction des connaissances sexuée
les représentations médiatisé compte
autant sinon plus que ce que bill
enfants dans son univers familial
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
objets de l'enfance notamment les jouets
les livres etc tout ça ça compte
énormément
il faudrait pas penser que ça n'a aucun
profil incidence sur la socialisation
des enfants contraire ça compte vraiment
beaucoup
donc elle nous explique par exemple même
si travail domestique est répartie
équitablement dans le couple des parents
que les enfants observent comme
observatoire enfantin et bien les
enfants lisent des livres regarde des
films etc et donc il faut observer par
exemple que le métier de pompier ils
vont voir que c'est que des hommes dans
les livres dans les jouets etc
c'est que des
donc ils vont penser que ma pompiers
c'est un métier d'homme points même
s'ils n'ont jamais vu d'hommes pompiers
en réalité ils vont penser aussi que le
travail domestique c'est plutôt quelque
chose de femmes même si dans l'exemple
que josé données et bien c'est réparti
équitablement dans leurs foyers
donc ça compte énormément alors la
segmentation restreint les eaux sage a
mis en route la segmentation restreint
plusieurs choses à l'appoint la liberté
les choix des enfants sont contraints
sertic ont des choix on a l'impression
que c'est leur goût un les parents et 10
moi je m'adapte au goût de mes enfants
mais en fait les goûts que les enfants
font ils sont contre 1 1
parce que les enfants sont socialisés on
leur enseigne des choses donc ça restera
la liberté ça restera également légalité
parce que finalement ça développe des
compétences qui ne sont pas les mêmes
chez les garçons les jouets vont être
pour les amener à beaucoup plus
développer leurs capacités motrices un
ça va leur enseigner à courir un marché
espère à se déplacer donc après quand on
observe que à les garçons sont plus
turbulents et c'est peut-être que c'est
vrai mais si c'est vrai ça veut pas dire
que c'est une ne savent pas forcément
dire que c'est une mais ça se construit
aussi et les jouets participe aussi de
cette construction sociale là du côté
des filles c'est plutôt tout ce qui est
lié au caire on appelle le caire le soin
à autrui la communication qui est
développée donc on dit oui les filles
aiment bien parler etc
les jouets laurent 5 ça il faut toujours
parler à son poupon etc
ça restera également la mixité parce que
finalement il ya moins d'échangés entre
les enfants un d'un côté et suit avec
leurs jouets puis l'autre côté les
garçons avec leurs jouets alors ça
permet aussi de développer
finalement des aspirations à la plante
sur le plan familial
et puis sur le plan aussi professionnel
donc il ya des enquêtes là dessus un qui
montrent que les enfants qui ont eu des
joueurs et stéréotypé finalement les
filles notamment finalement ont des
perspectives de carrière qui sont moins
larges d'envoyer une image de casa de
mythos nettoyer à deux c'est mieux
et on voit cette transmission familiale
entre la mère et la fille inquiets
qu'ils s'amusent beaucoup ensemble
après le ménage ensemble et voilà qu'ils
sont habillés de la même manière ont le
même ballet et cetera et cetera
on voit beaucoup d'image de ce type là
c'est très intéressant aussi parce que
ça permet de développer des manières de
tenir le corps vous avez certainement
remarqué que souvent les hommes et
femmes ne marche pas de la même manière
ne se contente pas de la même manière
non pas la même gestuelle etc
tout ça c'est pas forcément non plus une
et ça aussi ça peut se construire
donc toutes ces images le voyez moi je
les ai trouvé un petit peu partout dans
les catalogues mais quand on les
rassemble
quand on les met toutes ensemble eh ben
il ya quelque chose qui saute aux yeux
quand même hein on voit des signes
finalement des codes qui apparaissent
on voit au niveau des postures
corporelles voyez les prix ont elles
sont vraiment réels douce voilà les
petits
elles font des petites pauses comme ça
on a l'impression qu'elles peuvent
tomber parce que dans le talon un petit
peu surélevé où comme ça bon à tout
faire sinon je vais finir par tomber
celle du milieu moi je les aime beaucoup
et c'est ma préférée celle qui est comme
ça et puis les garçons contraire ils
sont comme ça droits dans leurs bottes
ils ont les poings sur les hanches ou en
l'air ils regardent méchamment et dont
vous voyez déjà ça n'indique pas les
mêmes valeurs aux enfants les visages
défis sont toujours des couverts et les
avec des garçons sont très souvent
cachés donc voilà il ya plein de choses
à analyser qui sont intéressantes par
rapport aux déguisements et ça développe
un des postures corporelles chez les
enfants alors quelles sont les actions
qui sont menées pour l'égalité des
différentes choses ah oui par exemple je
pouvais vous montrer ça ça ça peut être
intéressant par rapport aux postures
corporelles et par rapport au corps la
représentation des corps donc là vous
avez un axiome man que je verrai habillé
hop voilà
et là vous voyez la taille de sa main je
pense que vous voyez la taille de la
main de la barbie alors ils font la même
taille à peu près pourtant la taille de
la main de la barbie c'est
impressionnant la différence c'est qu'en
fait les mains chez les garçons c'est
vraiment représentée comme une arme
il se bat avec et ils peuvent aussi
prendre des armes envoyées la main elle
est comme ça ils peuvent attraper larmes
alors que la main de la barbie est comme
ça un poteau dans la représentation
alors quelles sont les actions qui
peuvent être menées en faveur de
l'égalité d'un déjà vous voyez la
poubelle à midi dont vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler qui a été créé il ya
quelques moins un par un artiste qui
finalement a pris les proportions
américaine moyenne d'une jeune fille de
18 19 ans qui a créé sa poupée alors la
mini schl a porté aussi si vous voulez
la voir en vrai elle est là et habile
xterra bon donc effectivement ça
ressemble pas trop à une barbie 1 et
pourtant ça peut aussi être amusant
sinon il ya la gamme petit mail ou aussi
qui est intéressante à observer qui a
été créée par la grande récré par le
groupe ludendo donc là je vais me une
image et qui vous la voyez là aussi une
bouilloire et donc ça c'est intéressant
ce qu'au niveau de la boîte vous voyez
c'est des couleurs orange et violet donc
c'est relativement neutre et du verre et
puis à chaque fois sur chaque boîte
yat email ou un garçon et une fille donc
ça indique que ces contrôles ont
évidemment tout s'est joué là ce sont
des jouets de limitation 1 notamment de
travail domestique c'est indique que
c'est pas uniquement pour les garçons
pour les filles il ya aussi des
initiatives qui sont prises par les
fabricants par les les distributeurs
dans leur catalogue par exemple
connaissez peut-être le catalogue hyper
u 1 en 2012 et aussi en 2013 avec ces
images atypique dont j'ai parlé au
départ et puis on voit finalement que
cette segmentation marketing c'est
quelque chose quand même de volontaires
parce que quand on vers leucate les
catalogues dano 1 sur internet ou ou le
catalogue papier on voit exactement la
même image à gauche par vous avez
uniquement un garçon en train de jouer
et à droite vous avez un garçon et une
fille c'est exactement la même image
donc on a rajouté les enfants donc il ya
la volonté comme de soi je mettre un
garçon soit je mettrai une fille ce jeu
met les deux bancs et puis en dessous
vous avez une fille toute seule la même
fille mais on lui a changé de tee-shirt
la couleur du tee shirt ne sais pas trop
pourquoi
ou avec un garçon est donc là on a au
danemark
est ce assez intéressante que le
danemark est un piquant même qui est un
petit peu connue pour l'égalité des
sexes de la même manière que la suède et
on observe que c'est moins segmenté que
c'est moins marqué on voit plus de
mixité dans les catalogues à la peau
danemark et en suède pour une enseigne
comme deux heureuses qui en france
saignements énormément donc une même
enseigne peut choisir de beaucoup
segmenté dans un pays est beaucoup moins
dans un autre évidemment en fonction
d'intérêts marchand 1 en fonction d'une
éthique et puis pour terminer on peut
parler aussi des stratégies des parents
qui ont un port keitel culturel à
ressasser les parents qui ont beaucoup
de diplômes mes parents qui ont beaucoup
de diplômes acquis vraiment veulent
orienter quand même leurs enfants parce
qu'il ya des gens qui n'aiment pas et
des jouets qu'ils aiment bien
les parents des milieux populaires en
général ils disent moi j'achète à mes
enfants les joies qui leur plaisent bon
dans la limite on pas que ce soit trop
gros trop encombrant faut pas qu'ils
aient déjà pas que ce soit trop cher
mais les joies qui leur plaisent la
référence et les goûts alors dans les
milieux plus favorisés la référence ya
les goûts mais il ya aussi autre chose
et où ils font vraiment attention à ce
que aussi ça diffuse certaines valeurs
ils se rendent compte que le jouet être
jours éducatifs et donc il ya plusieurs
stratégies qui peut utiliser notamment
la stratégie du dénigrement alors il ya
des maires par exemple qui vont dénigrer
les barbie en étant un tel regard elles
ont l'air cruche et cetera
et quand on interroge les enfants ils
seront ils se réapproprient ce discours
un et on les entend dire à rien elles
ont l'air cruche est très approprié
discours des parents finalement ils se
construisent leur goût par rapport à ce
qu'ils entendent ans donc il ya salle la
stratégie du dénigrement et la stratégie
aussi de la liste de noël
la liste de noël qui est très souvent
fait par les enfants
et du coup les les parents ensuite vont
sélectionner ce qui les intéresse et et
retirer le reste voilà alors il ya
d'autres choses ensuite qui se passe
dans les lieux d'accueil de la petite
enfance notamment un parfois il ya
certains certains jouaient à tous les
jouets sont en accès libre sauf que les
gens prendront pas forcément vers tous
les jouets un accès égal ne signifie pas
un usage égale donc finalement les
professionnels en france parfois vont
faire en sorte de faire des actions
positives de manière à faire en sorte
que les petits garçons par exemple aux
allées vers les poupées parce que
parfois ils en ont envie
ils ont peur du regard des autres et ne
le font voilà donc je vais conclure
voyez l'image là c'est un détournement
de barbie évidemment on construit tout
sans participent tous à la construction
du monde de demain qu'on soit par an ce
pcs du marketing de fabrication etc
tout le monde participe au monde de
demain donc finalement pour réfléchir au
monde que l'on veut demain et voir
ensuite quelles actions on peut mener
pour pour accéder à ce moment là je vous
remercie